[Music]
so we've talked rather extensively on
the show about the supposed eviction
crisis that we've been promised for some
time and it's because of this supposed
crisis that uh democrats
of course according to democrats anyway
the cdc must be allowed to continue
forbidding landlords from evicting
tenants who don't pay their rent never
mind the cdc doesn't have that authority
never mind that the policy deeply
infringes on the basic human rights of
property owners
we must they say allow these people to
remain in homes and apartments they
aren't paying for
and we must allow this indefinitely
no matter what
now i confess that i haven't been
persuaded by these arguments
up until now
because all of that changed uh with a
report just published in the hill which
i which i read yesterday here's the
headline
nearly half of lgbt renters behind on
rent fear eviction in next two months
and this is credited to research by the
way it says nearly half of lgbt renters
behind on rent fury eviction the next
two months colon research
well who could dispute that if research
has declared it
the research has spoken
but in any case i for one will
completely abandon my views on this
issue now that i know that some gay
people are impacted
i had no idea you know here i was
opposing
a destructive and insane and oppressive
government policy and then the hill
comes in and says well yeah but the
policy will help some gay people
well okay then never mind i stand
corrected
if gay people will be helped
please take all of my private property
rights take away the gun rights too and
free speech
take away my very life if you're if it
will help
if that would be beneficial to some gay
people i submit to the desires of our
lgbt masters do what you will my lords
i'm sorry for having defied you this
anyway is the reaction that we're
expected to have i guess here's the
article it says about half of lgbt u.s
renters who are behind on their payments
fear eviction in the next two months
according to research released by the
university of california los angeles
says williams institute the williams
institute compiled a brief examining
housing stability during the coronavirus
pandemic using data from the u.s census
bureau's pulse survey the research found
that 19 percent of lgbt respondents said
that they are behind on rent of those 47
so that they fear eviction the next two
months
the findings from the survey come after
the supreme court last week blocked an
eviction freeze put in place by the by
administration to shield financially
vulnerable americans during the pandemic
well did anybody explain this to the
supreme court
did anyone present this powerful legal
argument that the eviction freeze is
good because some gay people might be
evicted without it
was this legal case laid out to the
justices it should be if it hasn't been
uh some more from the article says
william institute researchers also found
that 41 of lgbt respondents rent their
homes compared to 25 of their straight
cisgender counterparts about 39 of lgbt
people owned a house with a mortgage or
a loan compared to almost 48
of non-lgbt people in addition more lgbt
people of color 47 rent their homes
compared to 37 of white lgbt respondents
51 percent of lgbt people of color said
that they feared eviction the next two
months compared to 38 of white lgbt
people uh 47 of non-lgbt people of color
and 46 of white non-lgbt people the
williams institute's brief concluded
that a key component of a person's
housing stability is whether they own a
rent
lgbt people and specifically those of
color are more likely to be impacted by
the kova 19 pandemic
a study released by the williams
institute in february
found that lgbt people of color were two
times more likely to contract kova 19
compared to their straight white
counterparts
well geez
now i'm against coveted two
on second thought i mean now that you've
told me that i'm i'm opposed to covet
i had no idea that my race and sexual
orientation afforded me immunity from
the virus
and now frankly i feel the ethical
responsibility to go out and get
infected on purpose
and to infect many other straight white
people
as well
just to kind of even out the score a
little bit
since we're keeping score apparently
now if it seems like i'm just heaping
sarcastic scorn here and offering
nothing else you're exactly right
because this kind of intersectional
madness
that's what it deserves
just our scorn and ridicule and sarcasm
there is no way to engage with it
honestly or coherent coherently anyway
because it's not put forward honestly or
coherently
just starting with the first sentence it
says about half of lgbt people behind on
their rent fear eviction well
yeah and
that's not the same thing as saying that
half of lgbt people period fear eviction
it's to say that half of the people who
are behind on their rent fear it
but shouldn't everyone who hasn't paid
their rent for your eviction
i mean should should the number be like
a hundred percent
this is like saying that that half of
lgbt people lgbt people who are
currently speeding down the road without
a seatbelt fear a fatal car accident
well yeah but that's good
it's not good that they're speeding
down the road uh you know recklessly
but it's at least good that they're
aware
of the consequences and they're mildly
concerned about it
so i have more questions about the other
half really
also you could easily flip this around
and you could phrase it the other way
and you could say nearly 100 of lgbt
people who pay their rent
do not fear eviction
so that's awesome looks like everything
is fine after all
but but here i am doing exactly what i
said i wouldn't do and we shouldn't do
engaging with the argument
because there's nothing really to engage
with here
the sexual orientation of people who
haven't paid their rent is of absolutely
no consequence or relevance at all
there's no reason to even talk about it
the wrongness or rightness of the
eviction moratorium
would not change one iota
if 100 of all lgbt people would be
evicted without it
why should it
i mean do the moral or legal facts
change depending on what identity group
the the affected people belong to
well yes that's exactly what the people
who do this kind of research and blast
it out in their headlines want us to
think
the point for them is really twofold
one
we're supposed to abandon our position
at the behest of a protected class of
people
you know
they say oh you're you're uh
you want to get rid of the eviction
moratorium well did you know
that if we do that there might be some
lgbt people who are evicted and we're
supposed to say well never mind
and two
the main thing here is that this now
enables the eviction moratorium
advocates to claim
that abolishing the eviction moratorium
is homophobic
and an anti-gay conspiracy
that's the setup
that's actually what they're doing here
so look for that talking point to be
rolled out shortly if it hasn't been
already
like clockwork entirely predictable but
no less insidious not to mention
ridiculous and annoying and insane
and for that reason the hill today
is of course
cancelled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated